it is the first of March 2023 so time
for another monthly update video I'm
going to talk about what we've got
coming up this month of March and what
you might have missed during February
and as always if you click see more in
the video description there'll be links
to all the things that I'm talking about
so the things that you might have missed
and want to go back to you can certainly
check out at your leisure I always like
to begin by highlighting three big
things on the horizon for the month
ahead and so here they are big thing
number one I haven't done any interviews
for quite a while I had that ideas that
matter series I'm restarting that and
some of them will be sit-down interviews
with people in the local area but many
of them will be carried out over zoom
and then we'll piece them together a lot
of cool interviews coming up with a lot
of cool people so stay tuned for those
big thing number two I also last month
restarted a series that I'd uh stopped
doing back in 2019
self-directed study in philosophy I did
a video on Descartes we're going to be
doing one on Hegel this month how to you
know productively study the guy on your
own so that's the second thing big thing
number three is also Hegel related we
have finally crossed over into the very
final section of hegel's phenomenology
which is big news for the half hour
Hegel project we're now doing videos on
absolute knowing I released the first of
them to my patreon supporters this last
month of February you'll see it coming
out soon in March and I'm going to be
recording a lot of other new videos on
that section and bringing the half hour
Hegel project to a long overdue and
successful close so that's what we've
got coming up let's talk now about
February
what went on in the month of February we
had a few local events I did the uh next
of the philosophers in the midst of
History I think we're either in year six
or seven of the series and I focused on
Socrates that's something that we have
at the Frank Weinberg Library I also uh
gave an invited talk at the Women's Club
of Wisconsin in the philosophy eats
um Series this one was because it was uh
February and Valentine's Day I talked
about four very interesting philosopher
couples one from Ancient One medieval
one early modern and one late modern and
then we did a lot of online stuff as
well so world's a speculative fiction we
covered the first four books of
sapkowski's Witcher series a really fun
set of novels to which I will be
returning again next year we also kicked
off the understanding anger online class
there's a video that you can watch of
the class session you can also sign up
for the class if you want to and that
allows you to participate in the
sessions that we do each month
I did a self-directed study video as I
mentioned just a few minutes ago on
studying Rene Descartes philosophy which
I think was a long overdue it had been
about three years since we did anything
in the series so that's underway once
again we had two
recording sessions and airings of the
wisdom for Life Radio Show episodes 63
and 64. last one was about red flags we
also talked about ethical implications
of of gambling and institutions around
it so some pretty cool stuff off and
then I did an update video about
becoming a philosophy professor and my
advice about that admirable but
difficult uh Prospect so those were a
lot of the events that went on I've also
been you know teaching my three academic
classes one at Marquette University on
anger and Justice another one online for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
called philosophy mindfulness in life
that is focused on philosophies as ways
of life so we're still in the hedonist
Traditions at this point after break we
jump into cynicism and stoicism
and then I'm teaching an intro to
Humanities class as well at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design we finished
up with Sophocles Antigone and we are
now studying Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
which is a lot of fun and I've been
doing a lot of work with clients as well
there's always a few new people coming
to me and
wanting to start you know services and
tutoring or philosophical counseling or
consulting or other various things and
I've been doing a bit of writing as well
working on a book project
I will also say that it's kind of cool
yesterday was Facebook reminded me an
anniversary of my first book actually
coming out 12 years ago right so that's
that's pretty cool as well
video work
um I did shoot a lot of video some
shorts that you may have seen mostly
having to do with animals and then we
finished up J.R tolkien's on fairy
stories sequence in the world's not the
worlds of speculative fiction and
speculative fiction studies this great
essay by him and then I I shot quite a
few core concept videos from my students
some on diogenese liertes and his his
discussions of aristipus and the cyranic
school a lot on lockedancius's short
work on anger I think I shot 10 or 11
videos on that and I did a lot of
podcast work as well uh finished up the
sequence that I had started the month
before on hume's inquiry concerning
human understanding we now have the
entire work covered in both video and
podcast form seneca's on anger book one
I did podcast episodes on that and the
stuff on diogenes Laertes uh book two on
aristipus in the Syrian ax school we
just finished up with the podcast
episodes on that as well so busy month
in February a little bit short it always
is you can never get as much done as you
want to what is coming up in the month
of March so on the first Saturday the
4th at noon we have our usual AMA ask me
anything session and it's you know live
chat you can show up and ask me about
whatever you want to within reason and
you know being civil of course and you
do want to get your questions in early
on because there is a tendency for them
to pile up as time goes on a little bit
later I will be having at two o'clock
Central Time my monthly philosophy chat
for patreon supporters that's a little
bit more intimate setting they can ask
me about anything as well but we've got
you know our cameras on we're meeting by
zoom on the 11 7th we'll have the next
self-directed study video and that is
going to be about Hegel I did a poll and
asked people well what you know Hegel
Hume Hobbs Augustine Hegel one so we're
going to be doing Hegel and how to you
know productively study him I'll have a
lot to say I think right so you pre you
definitely want to tune in for that and
when I say tune in for it I'll be
premiering the video and doing live chat
with the audience members while the
video airs then on the 15th we've got
another Hegel related thing at 5 PM
central time our monthly Hegel q a and
discussion session which is underwritten
by the supporters of the half hour Hegel
project on the 18th we will have our
monthly understanding anger 2.0 class
we're going to be looking at anger in
platonic dialogues now we're not going
to be getting to the big ones like the
Republic lick and you know other things
to talk about the tripartite soul like
the Timaeus and the phaedrus instead
we're going to be talking about a whole
bunch of other ones like the gorgeous
and the euthyphro and uh discussions in
the protagoras and what makes people
angry why do they get angry with each
other sort of an introductory
examination of the emotion in these
platonic dialogues so if you can join me
for that you have to sign up for the
class of course in order to get the the
link but uh it's certainly something
possible for you to do and the link is
down below as as well on the 25th uh
last Saturday of the month we will be
having the next worlds of speculative
fiction series uh first we start with a
video premiere at noon Central Time and
then at around 1 30 or so we switch over
to a zoom session so we can chat about
the things and and a little bit more
detail with each other and this time we
are starting Kim Stanley Robinson's red
green blue Mars Trilogy we're actually
going to be doing two different uh
sessions on it the first one we're going
to look at Red Mars and green Mars the
second one we'll look at Blue Mars and
then all those short stories that he has
in his collection the Martians so if
you're into let's call it ecological
science fiction
um well then you don't want to miss that
because these are some great books I've
been really enjoying reading them and
then finally we have another philosophy
eats at the the Woman's Club of
Wisconsin here in Milwaukee
um it's a uh you know kind of exclusive
restricted type of thing you can't just
walk in off the street and join in but
it's it's kind of cool it's a dinner and
we're going to be talking about Mary
woolstonecraft somebody who I'm a huge
fan fan of and we're doing that because
it's women's History Month we'll be
discussing this this important and often
overlooked uh author
um you know I'm
one of the good things about classes
this month is we do have spring break
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
their spring break uh starts next week
and then Marquette is the week after
that so you know that's some time for me
to get caught up on stuff and course
building and Grading and all the other
things that I've got going on I'm hoping
to get a lot more writing done this
month in medium and on my book projects
and uh you know there's other things
I've got to do so let's talk about video
Work obviously there'll be videos from
the events as there always are and from
the wisdom for Life recording sessions
um but I'm going to be doing a lot more
half hour Hegel you know I mentioned
that we have made it into the absolute
knowing section I want to start making
some progress through that and bring
this this project to a final close uh I
promise to get to book reviews last
month didn't get to them that's a big
project for this month getting cut up on
some of these reviews that I need to do
I want to start doing the interview
videos again and we're going to be
looking at whose schedules are
compatible with my own for that and then
I'm going to be doing some more Saddler
stories I didn't do any of this last
month although I had done quite a few in
the month before and I think it's time
for that and then we'll do some
follow-ups you know I did that advice
about becoming a philosophy professor
and I thought well there's other things
too like how do you do philosophy
outside of the academy or should you
major in philosophy it's time for an
update for that one or what about going
to graduate school what would be the
point of doing that so I'll be doing
those kinds of videos and then core
concept videos I've already started
shooting new core concept videos on
seneca's on anger and you might say wait
a second didn't you do that before on
book one now I'm doing book two and book
three
I'm also if I get to it I'm going to be
shooting some speculative fiction
studies videos and what will that be on
well a long time ago I did a poll about
which Philip K dick novel I should cover
next because you know I did uh Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep and the winner
in that poll was man in the High Castle
so I'm going to be talking about that
particular novel going through it all
the characters all the concepts all the
themes all the important stuff we're
going to be hitting that chalkboard and
talking about what's happening and that
and then I I do want to start doing more
shorts videos they're kind of fun to
experiment around with I've got some
more cat and dog footage and things like
that but I'm also going to start doing
some like philosophy proper shorts you
know talking about something briefly for
less than you know 59 seconds seeing
what I can pack in there and we'll do
that uh podcast so the Sadler's lectures
pop podcast I've already started
releasing these to my patreon supporters
we're going to be having
aquinas's discussions of anger coming up
in podcast form and then I'm going back
to Aristotle and working my way through
the videos that I did on book seven of
the Nico McCain ethics which has to do
with you know things like weakness of
Will and you know
brutality and self-control and those
sorts of things and then if we have the
time I will also be doing some podcast
episodes on pascals passes you know
again making taking the videos that I
did a while back and turning them into
podcast episodes improving the sound
taking out all the amazas and and things
like that and repeated words which it
turns out I do a lot
so that is what we've got coming up in
March I hope that you have a great month
ahead and that you can meet up with me
either in person or in some of these
virtual events that we have scheduled
you can take a look at the reason I owe
event calendar and you you know or look
in Facebook and see when these events
are coming up and get in on that action
so I will see you there and I hope you
have a great month ahead